every time I talk about diffie-hellman
and use any kind of analogy people were
like oh show us the math show us the
maps I could have taken the mass so this
is for the mass people where if you want
to know how mathematically
diffie-hellman works watch this video if
you don't want to know that there's a
nice clothes button in the top corner or
a back button you know be my guest so
that this is for mathematically inclined
people let's go back to where we were
before so we have Alice and we've got
Bob and we've got our public area here
sort of public public and we go draw
down here now the mathematics behind
diffie-hellman is usually modulo
arithmetic
recall that we have our public numbers G
and M G is often very small is usually a
small prime number n is often very big
and needs to be big for the security of
this to work and is often 2,000 bits
long or 4,000 bits is more common now so
n is very very big it can't be too big
because you won't gain much in security
but you lose in efficiency so you know
you have to think about that Alice and
Bob need to pick their numbers a and B
so Alice picks a number a Bob picks a
number B these are the ones they're
going to keep private now a is somewhere
between 1 and n but it's random and n is
so vast but it's not going to be 1 it's
gonna be a very big number it's not
worried about what it is she's not gonna
tell anyone what that is same for Bob
the first thing is does if she
calculates G to the power of a mod n
right now modulo if you do any
programming you'll be familiar with it's
a percent symbol is the remainder after
division so another way of looking at
modulo is to have this kind of clock
face so if we have a clock face which
should be a circle and we go from 1 2 3
all the way round to n these are the
numbers modulo n 4 when we perform some
arithmetic in this space we just go
around and man the clock face we don't
ever leave and go above in or below zero
in fact if this should be 0 as well this
should be a zero in here so when you do
G to the power of a mod n what happens
is you're raising G to the power of some
massive number which would be very
normally very big but in actual fact it
just goes round around this clock face
and ends up somewhere so let's say G to
the a mod n arrived somewhere here on
the clock face now what's important
about this is it's very difficult
given this to work out what a was we
know jeez let's say three right if I say
we are here on the clockface and we
started at three what number is a it's
just impossible to know right because
it's position on this clock has no
bearing on how many times has gone round
or what ie was at all right the only way
to do this is essentially to brute force
it to go well is it a ^ 1 no it's not is
it a - the power to know and and so on
and so forth for an infeasible amount of
time well we did a little bit of this
with the hashing video didn't we there
was a little bit of the modulo function
there in in calculating the hash yes so
that was used to shorten something at
the end but it's the same kind of
principle
mojo is very useful for taking something
but it could be any length and putting
it into a sort of finite loop a finite
group of actual numbers now Bob we're
going to take G to the B mod n so let's
say that turns off over here somewhere
so this is G to the B mod n so again
what we've done is we've taken G we've
raised it to the power of B and we've
done all of this modulo n which means
that it just if it ever goes above in it
just loops back down to 0 and keeps
going so this is somewhere else these
are very public components so they share
these like this so now these are public
but again calculating a and B from this
is very very difficult
it's called solving with discrete log
problem and practically very very
difficult for even a supercomputer all
right now Alice is going to take this
I'm just going to simplify the notation
slightly to make it fit on the page but
as it's going to take the G to the B but
Bob sent and raised it again to the
power of a mod n and Bob is going to
take G to the a that Alice sent and
raise it to the power of B mod N and
anyone that's done any exponentiation
knows that if you do something to the
power of something to the power
something else it's actually just those
two things multiplied so G it's G to the
a B mod n that's the answer so that will
put you that will come somewhere around
you know let's say here so this is G to
the a B mod n now this will be some
number between 0 and n Bob's done the
same thing he's also got G to the a B
and and they're exactly the same these
are two identical colors we were looking
at in our color example so they've both
arrived at the exact same position in
this group despite the fact that neither
the knew what each other's private key
was that's what's really cool about
Tiffany Hellman to try and reverse this
process we have to know a or B we know
publicly G to the a and we also know G
to the B if we try and multiply them
together for example we'll get G to the
a plus B which is not the same right
that's me sort of mixing my public
colors together in the hope of getting
to my answer I haven't done it that
would be someone else a completely
different number remember this is
cryptography if your one position out
not gunning it's not going to decrypt
okay so you know you have to get it
exactly right the fact that she's got G
to the B to the a E is no different to
GT v8 in a bit it's exactly the same I
mean you could you could look at an
example if you went to to the power of 2
to the power of 3 that's 2 times 2 times
2 times 2 times 2 times 2 right which is
2 to the 6 because there's this stick to
them you can do it in any order it
doesn't matter you get the same number
out at the end whereas that is a
completely different thing yeah so that
is equivalent of 2 to power of 2 times 2
to power 3 which is 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 times 2 which is 2 to the 5
entirely different number now those
numbers are fairly similar because these
examples are small you guys going to be
somewhere else completely honest on this
movement it clockface
you're not gonna it's not gonna work at
all the N number is kind of important
though is it right it's mostly important
that n is big because if n is small then
in essence this clock face is going to
have only a few numbers on it you can
brute-force that very quickly right you
can find the value of a or the value of
B and reverses process if n is you know
astronomically large like 2,000 or 4,000
bits the amount of time it's going to
take you to find the correct the correct
values for a or B is I mean it
essentially is long enough that you
won't bother that's the argument it's
technically possible but you would be
long dead by the time you did it and so
you're you finding out what image they
send each other it's not about useful
actually this is this is quite simple
right I mean let's not under play this
is incredibly important for computer
science and mathematics but it's
actually not that complicated in some
sense it's very elegant if you want to
see some worked examples of this
Wikipedia and other websites have lots
of small examples with small numbers so
that you can work this through if you
want to have a go at the math yourself
right and you'll get the same answer out
and it's you know it's impressive